Martin Gilbert author of Churchill a
life what's your favorite story not
Winston Churchill I have so many really
always one for each occasion my favorite
story is the cover you're holding up
this picture was suppressed for 43 years
it was taken when Churchill was in the
middle of the Second World War he was
feeling confident but he just won
Roosevelt's support for the war effort
in Europe gone up to Ottawa he won the
Canadian Parliament round and he was
stopped by a photographer in the
corridor took that lovely picture and
the photographer was dissatisfied and
Churchill put his cigar in his mouth and
started lighting out the photographer
grabbed the cigar and got the famous
frowning disagreeable Churchill was
grazed every postage stamp and every
other book cover and for which millions
incidentally made in photographic feed
and it's not the real Churchill I mean
you know if I were to punch you in the
face and then take a picture whoever saw
you like that except me and so my
favorite picture is this one and it's
the real Church of this morning - how
did you get it from the cover I was
promoting the English edition of the
book in Canada in May and found that on
my floor of the hotel where the
publishers had put me was the studio of
this photographer by sheer chance I
didn't even know he was still alive so I
knocked on his door walked in was a ding
I going into a haberdasher shop and I
took it from there my combination was to
get rid of all these myths and
carbuncles you know the war monger the
disagreeable man the imperialist with no
vision so I thought the cover should
reflect that did you spend much time
around Winston Churchill in 1961 which
is exactly 30 years ago and as a young
kid of 25 I was asked by his son to join
a team rather chaotic team of people who
are trying to help Randolph his son in
preparing this great multi-volume
biography and that's where I really
learned my my trade I mean I was the one
who had to go through the original
papers and bring them to Randolph my
section
of the history and there I was touching
his letters finding his school reports
sometimes even opening envelopes that
have been sealed in 1894 1895 and
certain away from then from that moment
for 30 years he was with me I suppose
every day of my life though I never
smoked a cigar what year did he die he
died in 965 three years after I started
work for Randolph and I was actually
over here then in the States
and I had a wonderful discovery which
really gave me roundels confidence and
put an even deeper into the Churchill
story I went to a New York Public
Library and I knew the Churchill had had
a friendship an American Tammany Hall
boss in New York and I asked to see the
Churchill file in that man's papers he
was called Bourke Cockran
and they said oh we're terribly sorry we
only have the letters from the American
novelist Winston Churchill was such a
person and it was so cold outside that
day I said well all right let me look at
those and they turned out to be all the
letters from my Winston Churchill they'd
been misfiled and they included a letter
he'd written from prison camp
on his 25th birthday a long fascinating
letter so from that moment randal
thought I was a genius thought it was
worm it's filing under and we went from
strength to strength ice to go from
archive to archive me
I met all his old girlfriends the girls
he proposed to who turned him down and
the girls had wanted him to marry their
man who he'd turned down including the
girl who was so angry that he didn't
want to marry her that she said you know
Winston all you men are the same you are
absolutely rotten and he said you're
quite right he said we're all worms but
I do believe I am a glow it's hard to be
honest with you it's hard to know where
to start but let me start with you
have you been known as the official
biographer I'm called the official
biographer though to the enormous credit
of the Churchill family they never asked
to see a single word of what I was
writing until the books were printed and
bound and ready for sale to the public
and they never asked me to delete a word
or
to skirt round a particular issue so
official is a misnomer if it's thought
to mean a censored or restricted
biographer what does it mean to be the
official ban if in some Paul Sartre had
to be willing to give 30 years of his
working life give up his university
teaching give up his lecturing give up
the amenities of being as it were a club
herbal dawn on an Oxford University High
table and be willing to sit in archives
which I enjoyed I don't complain about
one moment but basically it meant you
know someone who did full-time day after
day for 30 years
what part of Winston Churchill do you
enjoy researching the most what I mean
by that is he was an artist Eve orator
he was a writer he was a statesman and
he was a leader what part got your most
of most of your attention I think the
thing which fascinated me most was his
work as a parliamentarian he entered
Parliament in in 1900 he was a young he
was just 25 years old and and he spent
the next 55 years in the parliament and
he made that his life I presumed he
wrote every single one of his
parliamentary speeches nowadays it's
quite rare as you know for a leading
figure to write his speeches he might
correct what is his speech writers right
and he not only wrote them but he
rewrote them he he worked on them and
it's a common misconception that he just
sort of used words in an airy-fairy
way I'm the famous phrase by Jeff
Kennedy he mobilized English language
and sent it into battle was true but he
used language for argument to leave the
House of Commons again and again
thousands of occasions through a
complicated and unpopular argument you
know he was arguing for example you
something you've got here in the United
States since 1933 a minimum wage which
our government still resists he
presented at the British Parliament you
know it for an hour and a half in great
and careful detail so that really is
fascinating how did this man take in
unpopular calls and persuade a basically
often hostile House of Commons to accept
that the rightness and logic of it
because he was never a dictator he could
never pound the table and say we'll do
it everything depended on the votes of
the house of come and the years he lived
from wenda when he was born in 1874
and he died in 1965 so it was a long
life he passed his 90th birthday and his
foot the first president whom he met was
McKinley and he fortunately also met
McKinley's vice President Teddy
Roosevelt because shortly after he met
McKinley McKinley was assassinated and
Rahzel became president and he knew
Woodrow Wilson well and had many debates
with him over whether the Bolsheviks
should be contained by the Allies in
1918 or whether they should be allowed
to stew in their own juice
Churchill believe that the
anti-bolshevik Russians should be
assisted to overthrow Bolshevism and
Woodrow Wilson declined
he knew Franklin Roosevelt extremely
well they were the war leaders in World
War two and he knew Truman and great too
respected Truman he was in a way the
encourage of the fort became the Truman
Doctrine in foreign affairs he
encouraged America to emerge as a world
leader and Eisenhower was somebody with
whom he had when Eisenhower was
president a most incredible conflict and
it wasn't personally violent but it was
almost disastrous for Churchill
Churchill wanted when Stalin died to go
with Eisenhower Moscow and meet Stalin
successors in Moscow and say right now
we can end the Cold War now we can know
we are strong we have the nuclear
capacity but we wish to be on good terms
with you we wish to help your economy in
return for you moderating your
dictatorship he said let's at least go
to Moscow an Eisenhower refused and very
much humiliated Churchill both to
Churchill's cabinet and also in the
international discussion Churchill never
left it alone for four years he kept
coming back to it
pleading with Ike let us try and break
the Cold War but you know it was the
wrong time in American politics and in
the end it was Reagan and Gorbachev and
Bush and Gorbachev and Thatcher and
major who did what he had pleaded with
Ike to do you say 55 years did he spend
all that time in the parliament was he
there all those years he only had a year
and a half out of Poland and that was in
1922 when he had to fight an election
but he just had his appendix out and he
used to joke he said
one stroke I lost my place in the
government my seat in parliament and my
appendix all three had gone but he came
back after a year and a half and even
the famous wilderness years when there's
a misconception actually in America that
he was alone in fact was even a book
come out remember the author which says
lion alone he was never alone in the
wilderness he as he had an enormous
following in Parliament in the
government circles in the civil service
and among the public who realized that
his warnings but Hitler did have to be
confronted if war was to be avoided he
had to be told look that's far and no
further he was always in Parliament
during those wilderness years so he
always had you know his place he was
actually on the front bench of those who
your viewers know from the British
Parliament quite a powerful place to be
and so his was always a voice within the
parliamentary system he was never really
out of it and of course Churchill out of
office was a man who went down to his
country house Chartwell in Kent and had
around him probably more cabinet
ministers and government officials than
sat around the cabinet I mean he was a
magnet he was fun he was fun to be with
he was he was interesting he when he was
serious it was something worth you know
being present at and so people flocked
him almost like moths to a lamp he
married how many times only once he was
in love with a beautiful girl whom he
met in India went riding on elephants in
his youth around the city of Hyderabad
in southern India but she somehow wasn't
quite for him then he met a pretty girl
and hardly noticed her at dinner and at
the end of the dinner he said I'm sorry
I didn't talk to you but I've written a
book about my father may I send it to
you she said yes she rather liked him
and she never heard again from him that
was a girl called Clement heed they met
four years later he had forgotten the
promise which he hadn't given of sending
the book and he fell in love with her
and proposed to her even then though he
was terribly indecisive we think of him
as a man who knew what he wanted and
went how to get it he wanted to marry
her but he didn't know how to do it and
he invited her to blend him where his
family lived and they spent the weekend
together and his cousin's noticed he
wasn't popping the question
he wasn't asking her on the final
morning when she was due to go to London
he was lying in bed and his cousin the
Duke went into his bedroom and said
stern you've got to get out of bed he
hated getting out of bed in the morning
you've got to get out of bed and propose
so finally he got out he went into the
garden he couldn't bring himself to do
it
it came on to rain the two of them went
for shelter into a littles of ornamental
temple and there he finally said will
you marry me and she said yes and from
that moment he had nobody else in his
life and she was a wonderful woman not
because she was somehow just ornamental
but as you'll see from the book whenever
she felt he was going wrong whenever she
felt his character was perhaps
disintegrating a bit he was becoming a
little rough she would send him notes
beautifully written notes Winston you're
not doing the right thing don't do this
and written with with love but also with
great firmness so she was was more than
just an ornament really at his table
they were married for how long they were
married in 1908 and when he died in 1965
they were they were still married had
how many children at five children one
who died as a little child of meningitis
before she was three which is a sad
episode in their lives they had a son
Randolph whom I worked for it was
wonderfully rambunctious and had a
wonderful family life that a church will
belong to that generation perhaps it's
almost gone now who believed that ever
the family should always be there I mean
if a Prime Minister was coming to tea or
Secretary of State was coming to dinner
you had your family around the table and
you didn't inhibit the talk and indeed
if the family was young as Churchill's
family were of course when they were
young you had games he had a lovely game
which which who played the blue cap the
next person said the bright cat the next
one said the bold got the brave cat you
tried to exhaust the adjectives
beginning with B and if there's a
Secretary of State or somebody there he
joined you know he was invited to join
in and in this way the children grew up
surrounded by by the most marvelous
politics and humor and sometimes they
had awful roles and on one occasion
Churchill was sort of laying down the
law about something and suddenly
Randolph began to lay down the law
Churchill looked at him and said stop
interrupting me when I'm interrupting
but they enjoyed themselves and animals
were part of the of the show there was
lots of cats and lots of dogs like I
discovered he's always thought of as the
Bulldog in British history and I
discovered that when he was a schoolboy
at the age of 11
I put it in the book is so nice he sold
his bicycle in order to have enough
money to buy a bulldog there are some
things direct American connections his
mother his mother was born in Brooklyn
the little plaque where she was born in
Henry Street she was raised in Rochester
and he always used to save himself I'm
half American and wholly British and his
enemies said of him
you're half alien and wholly
reprehensible that was a different
kettle of fish he once used his mother's
American connection to very powerful
effect he wanted in 1941 in the spring
to broadcast the American people to try
to explain from why Britain was at war
and why sooner or later the United
States would find itself in this world
and clearly you know he couldn't do this
officially Roosevelt you know couldn't
challenge the isolationist by such a
method or it would have been awful for
him politically so the two of them
arranged they were great conspirators
together in the interests of democracy
and defeating tyranny they arranged for
President Valentine the University of
Rochester to invite Churchill to get an
honorary degree because it was where his
mother grew up and of course he couldn't
come over in the war with the battle
Atlantic so he said as if Apple do I
tell you what President Valentine why
don't I broadcast my acceptance speech
well of course once you're broadcasting
across the Atlantic it can be picked up
everywhere from New Orleans to Seattle
and from Bangor to San Diego and so he
made his wonderful broadcast to the
American very understanding of the
American predicament not occurring would
say sooner or later all good forces must
confirm the evil forces and when you do
it you have to be confident that you
know why you're doing it and you have to
be very strong to face the setbacks that
will come on the way our viewers when
they watch the British House of Commons
see a Winston Churchill on the floor of
the Commons today who is he
that is Churchill's grandson and indeed
there is a nice American connection
there because his mother Pamela is mrs.
Patton ahem
lives here in Washington and was a
Churchill side during the Second World
War and there are some lovely stories in
the book which she recounts she was
often with him late at night when
desperate military moves were imminent
and she was one of the people who
witnessed in the intimacy of his study
just how concerned he was about the fate
of those who were inevitably going to
die in these assaults it wasn't for him
a game or Oh or a statistic he somehow
felt the plight of every soldier and and
it was because he had been a young
soldier his mother his American mother
had been given task after task by
Churchill starting from the task get me
to London during Queen Victoria's
Jubilee in 1887 when he was twelve he
didn't want to see the Queen he wanted
to see Buffalo Bill Cody and Annie
Oakley or performing at ELLs caught in
five hundred Indians and God knows how
many buffaloes and he instructed his
mother later get me to the scene of
action get me to where the wars are
intently not to fight he was a
newspaperman and of course a
newspaperman it's no good you know Peter
Arnett sitting in the Savoy in London he
has to be in Baghdad and so Churchill
was always saying to his mother you know
get me to the scene of action and she
did and this was her sort of great roles
he was the the pusher he once said if
Ave disarmingly my mother left no stone
unturned
she left no cutlet uncooked and indeed
she she really worked hard to entertain
on on his behalf and so he saw war at
first hand thanks to his mother and he
saw the cruelties of war and he was
always saying to fellow politicians the
supreme object of statesmanship is to
stop war happening in fact I found
something he wrote which moved me very
greatly I put it in the book in 1908
--all which many British people
regardless of great victory in South
Africa excited
the flags went out he wrote a piece
about it a journalistic piece he'd been
at the battle but he ended his piece if
modern man of light and leading would
see the face of war more often ordinary
folk would see it hardly ever
you've got ten hundred and this is huge
ten hundred sixty-six pages in here but
this is the font is this going to be the
final this is it all in one body from
cradle to grave how many volumes have
you written
I wrote six of the eight volumes of the
official narrative and I produced eight
volumes of documents it's letters and
documents in fact I'm now doing his war
document but this is everything boiled
down to one it's a sort of hopefully a
delicious consomme of Churchill's I ever
count the number of words you've written
about Winston Churchill I never did but
very much to my embarrassment the
Guinness Book of World Records did and
they put it in a slow longest biography
in English language but as I'm not a
believer that writing is quality because
of length I'm or slightly well not
ashamed of it but it's a bit bizarre
it's about eight and a half million
words but you know I started with 15
tons weight of his letters and papers so
you know it had to be constantly reduced
and sifted through and I even read his
laundry list people said what can you
possibly learn from a laundry list you
certainly can't publish laundry lists
but on one occasion I found a laundry
list from Beirut from a Beirut hotel and
I thought to myself I did I didn't know
when church was in Beirut and from that
laundry list it had a date
I discovered a journey which was not as
it were in the history book which he'd
made to the Middle East to Beirut and
then to Amman and then to Jerusalem and
then I found British officials young
rich officials at the time who had been
there that year 1934 and even then
acquired some historical documents about
his views and thoughts during that visit
so laundry lists have their uses - where
did you grow up I was born in London and
my parents were Londoners and when I was
two and a half the the war began and my
father was doing war work he was doing
night work and so when I was three and a
half I was put on a ship with hundreds
of other kids without my parents and
sent to Canada and Churchill
incidentally had been against this he
regardless or sort of scuttle and when
one of the ships were sunk and children
drowned
ground he stopped it so I was there with
about 4,000 other kids in Canada and I
discovered and I was writing this book
that in 1944 just at the time in the
Normandy landings Churchill saw that the
Mauretania great ocean liner which had
been converted to a troop ship was in
New York anchored on the Hudson and
there were only 3,000 troops going back
on it to Britain calls the American
forces already over there so he said why
not bring the children back in Canada so
telegrams were said and I was among the
children who was rounded out I was put
on a train by myself in Toronto station
well most vivid memories of my life is
arriving I was then seven and a quarter
Grand Central Station with a label
around my neck Grand Central and it
still looks for big big station but then
for a little boy it was very big and a
lie member the great sort of lines and
soldiers and normals crowd and I waited
patient I don't think I cried and
finally someone came and said little boy
come with me as they hot June day and 44
and I was led to the docks I went back
there the day for yesterday to see thee
appear when we embarked and then I found
in Churchill's papers a little note
where he put against the Mauretania
story in mauritania file make sure there
are enough lifeboats on board for the
extra children now that's interesting
asthma this man who then was having to
defeat Hitler in Normandy counter the
flying bomb deal with a whole problem of
defeating Japan still remember the extra
kids on the ship better make sure
they're enough lifeboats in case the
ship goes down would you go to school I
went to school at Highgate which is a
private school in London when the war
was over my father brought me back to
London he'd been evacuated himself to
North Wales and suddenly it was the
first day of the school term and dad had
made no arrangements I mean he'd been
involved in the war you know many people
in that boat so he put me in a car of a
friend and we drove round London till he
found a school which had a place for one
little boy it was a boarding school I
was then eight and a half and I went to
that school from 1945 to 1954 and then I
went into the British Army and
when I finished my military duties my
military service I went up to University
so I was somehow a boarder all my life I
was at boarding school in the army of
course you're you're in your barracks
and at Oxford you're there very
pleasantly in you know students lodgings
at Oxford and finally I graduated 1960
and a year later round off Churchill
said join my team do you have any reason
to know why he did I mean was there some
specific thing that caught his attention
I came to you yes immediately after I
graduated I wrote a book with my very
first pupil miles Percival Richard Gott
who later became a distinguished
journalist on the Guardian we wrote a
book called the appeases together with a
excited by it we were young historians
exposing somehow Neville Chamberlain's
not just his desire to postpone war but
it is his desire to get on good terms
with Hitler we found a lot out about
that and one of Randall's friends read
it and she said to Randolph you really
ought to get this young man talked to
him she used a lovely phrase in her
letter which he showed me he is full of
zeal to said history right and anyway he
started sending me telegrams and I'd
heard of him only as a terrible drunk
and right wings or sashes beasts of you
know the portrayal of students of those
days but finally the the head of my
college who had actually been
Churchill's research assistant in the
30s 40s and 50s
said to me you know why don't you go
you'll have an amusing evening you'll
have a lot of stories to dine out on and
you know you'll come back the next
morning well I went I had an amusing and
amazing evening and the next morning
instead of coming back randall said to
me will you join my team and I joined it
I thought I'd last four or five months I
lasted five years he died I thought I'd
write the biography what was left to be
done in five or six years and I finished
it a multi-volume
three years ago were you around him when
he died well I was actually on holiday
when he died the whole thing was very
distressing because in his last month's
roundels not well but he he had a
wonderful brain I had a lot of respect
for Randall he loved history he was full
of zeal for setting it right talking
about the Sun and Sun right and
he once said to me no Martin I'm not
interested in white washing my father
I'm in stood in the truth and he was
there was such a thing as historical
truth for him and indeed I hoped for me
and in the last year of his life the
Kennedy family asked him to write the
biography of of Jeff Kennedy and he was
very very understandably flattered by
that and and moved by that and so as
well as continuing with the biography in
the last year with the church' biography
he became who like distracted by the
challenge of Kennedy I mean he intended
to finish Churchill first on the other
hand he couldn't quite bring himself not
to sort of begin thinking about the
Kennedy and Robert Kennedy was the
member of the family who had really sort
of asked him to do it in fact I listen
dear life as my job doesn't into the
phone conversation when Robert Kennedy
asked him and then Robert Kennedy was
assassinated and round-off died within
24 hours of each other
1968 68 and suddenly the whole pack of
cards collapsed it was a great tragedy
and but I respected roundel Churchill he
wanted to tell his father story and when
I was writing my volumes of digne I was
writing this volume I always thought you
know not only would Winston Churchill
you know sort of feel I was doing it
properly but would Randolph that
Churchill think when people say to me oh
well he was just an alcoholic there's a
new book out about him as an alcoholic
and the whole Churchill family is
drinking I think well you know with me
we had many long days and nights when
you know his mind was crystal clear and
history was what we were doing and
getting his father's story right was
what we were about and he told lovely
stories about his father some of which I
was able to put in my book you know when
he told his stories used to if I would
laugh he'd say that's for my book not
your book and of course poor Randolph
died and the stories ended up in my book
is there such a thing it's built up over
the years as a Martin Gilbert Inc in
other words where have you got a big
force behind you that helps you do
research and secretaries I've always
believed in doing it oneself I've always
done all my own research I was very
lucky indeed but I always had one person
to help me you know sort the files and
go with me to the archives
if only because under the British system
one person can only call for three files
but two people can call for six and one
of my assistants Larry arm is now
running a policy study unity in Clermont
in California he was extremely good
unfortunately fell in love with my
secretary so he married her and she's
also in California and then I got
another assistant who came and this is
in 1971 and I fell in love with her so
she is now my wife and in fact she has
been ever since my we sit together and
we read every document together and I
then write the chapter
she then reads it and says wait a minute
you haven't properly interpreted that
document or you haven't got the best out
of it or you exaggerated what it says so
it's been the two of us and the whole
biography I wrote in pen and ink in fact
I this is the pen I wrote the 8th volume
with as a pen and ink man and then my
wife said so this one volume we have to
become modern creatures this one I want
to see what their appearances it's
called a pelican it's a serviceable in
British pen I think it may be French I'm
not sure I bought in some US can you
rate the entire eight volume yes with
that pen and then I bought another pen
to write this volume with and my rice
they put it away we have to become
modern and so I acquired a computer and
I wrote this on computer and I am us I
enjoyed it enormously though I did at
one point put in at ease which I forgot
to eliminate off from the disk but it's
not in the American edition the British
Edition has it but i deleted it for the
american edition this volume costs $35
do you have any idea as we sit here how
many nice things you'll sell III believe
that about 35,000 have sold it came out
on the 1st of November so it's had water
almost a month run three four weeks run
and it's now in its the second reprint
is out and hopefully third fourth fifth
reprint if your viewers all rush to buy
it I I would guess it has it hopefully
it'll go on selling because it is the
one the soul one volume work which
contains his his most personal store
it's most personal levels and everybody
said you'll never do it in one more
there are many multi volumes mostly
incomplete but you know many people have
tried a multi volume including myself
and you know the average man in the
street can't carry around an eighth
volume or even a three-volume set of OGG
can you buy the eighth volume set at one
stop you can actually and it's now come
out in England in paperback so it's even
physically much more manageable but you
know my idea was a one-volume you know
we live in an age where you know much as
one would like to sit down and read
books I mean even I just walk today
Carlile's history of the French
Revolution in Georgetown in an abridged
versions I wanted to reread it and I
thought you know I ought to read the
three volumes but you can't
so here's Churchill in one volume he
fits I mean you know there's more to say
but there's so much there that you know
it's it's you know though I sometimes go
on holiday to a village in the VOC clues
and the nearest town is called apt in
southern France and there they have a
cake called an apt en when you're really
feeling a bit peckish and it's a sort of
fruitcake which only has fruit if you
note I mean there's a bit of cake and a
lot of fruit na I like to feel this is
the book fruity one more question on the
eighth volume how much would it cost
today if you bought all Avon and can you
buy it hard backers are just paper you
can get it in hardback and get it in
paper in paperback the whole thing would
be about well eight times 280 pounds was
that about $100 hundred twenty dollars
more now be 100 hundred and fifty
tonight yes 150 dollars the hardback
eight volumes would be more like 220 230
dollars if Winston Churchill were alive
today and lived in this country and had
to join an American political party any
idea what he'd be based on what he
thought what he sent would he care well
he had belonged to both the equivalent
of the Democratic Republican Party's
he'd been a liberal and a conservative
how many years in each party about the
same twenty very active years as a
liberal or former social reformer and a
minimum wage man and at what point is
like from the age of thirty to fifty so
he started off as a conservative in the
house he was briefly conservative but
hated the the then
are in nature of the conservative party
and also he hated its aggressive
imperialism so they joined the Liberals
became a great pioneer of social reform
he introduced widows pensions orphans
pensions he introduced the whole system
of fair deal at the workplace you know
the break for meals for people in
enterprises he believed that everybody
in their workplace the camera man behind
your cameras should have a share in the
profit of the company so he were he was
in that sense of radical and then he
became a conservative in 1924 when he
was already 50 and as a conservative was
a very good conservative cause he
believed in the defense of the realm of
something paramount and he he believed
in not groveling to dictators or not
giving into bullying internationally but
he wanted what his father had called
Tory democracy a conservatism with a
genuinely classless face as interesting
that John Major our new and in my view
excellent conservative Prime Minister
has spoken of his desire to establish a
classless society which was really what
Churchill was struggling for as to the
parties he always said I have belonged
to both political parties and then he'd
say with a smile and I despised them
both equally you'll say and my guess is
he would join one of the two American
parties and tried to change it he would
try to change it in the direction he
wanted he had enormous I mean I've
looked at you know the Democrat and
Republican programs and he had enormous
sympathy for four things in both of them
which essentially I mean he thought the
supreme goal of staking ship was in
international affairs to preserve peace
but not at all costs in others preserve
peace unless the tyranny or the threat
was such that it had to be confronted
and had to be defeated and at home to
maintain the genuine unity of the nation
that's to say there should be nobody
whether it was race or economic
situational creed nobody who had an
inferior position in society and I nor
my welfare handouts believed in free
enterprise but that the poorest person
should have the opportunity to avail
itself of what free enterprise could
provide a purse and for that reason he
even when he was in charge of the
prisons as home sector that would be
sector the entire
he he fought very hard to give prisoners
people who are convicted criminals the
the same opportunities once they were
released from prison to rise in society
and indeed he introduced programs in
prisons to enable them when they came
out - as he put it established
themselves quickly in the world of
Industry and going to be rehabilitated
he even abolished that the system
whereby the police controlled prisoners
once they were released and introduced
what we call the probation system where
an independent probation service and non
police service supervises prisoners and
incidentally it was Robert Kennedy who
became very interested in Churchill's
philosophy of the rights of even a
convicted criminal against the state in
other words you couldn't push any group
of society down and say we're not
interested in you and he fought very
hard for example for those who had
disabled at work he believed the state
had some sort of obligation should make
some contribution to people like that to
enable them to to lead a decent life the
other thing which I think is going to be
a feature of current politics and either
the Democrats or the Republicans can
grasp it it's up to you know their
political genius he believed that at
some point the emphasis in industrial
societies must move from hours of work
which in his day he progressively
reduced you know you made the hours of
work less onerous less long that the
shift should be from hours of work to
hours of leisure that in the end the
statements concern itself with the
ability of people to use and exploit
their leisure time that facilities
should be provided that's why when
somebody once asked him in World War two
you know where do you want yours where
do you want your statue to go when
you're dead the great war leader he said
I don't really want a statue I would
like that to be parks in areas where
people have no parks so that those
people whose leisure time cannot include
walking in a park will have a park and
is instantly when he died and also moved
to set up his statue that the one that's
in Parliament Square
now his widow Clement he wrote to the
London Times pointing out this that her
husband actually had not wanted statues
but hearts
eight cabinet positions in his life yes
he entered the British Cabinet in well
long time ago in 1908 when he was still
in his mid thirties and he was last in a
cabinet in 1955 [ __ ] I was very
interested to discover quite by chance I
met all the members of its final cabinet
and they recall once was still alive
which was the majority and I knew Antony
Dan and Harold Macmillan and they both
helped me enormously with my work some
of their recollections are there and one
of them said you know we were we all
said goodbye to him and it was the day
before his his official retirement from
public life and he said there are two
things I'd like to say to you he said
first we'll always remember that man is
spirit and secondly said never be
separated from the Americans now he
didn't make a great oratorical flow just
these two little points man is spirit
which he always believed he always
believed man had the capacity for
self-improvement he was always an
optimist in the ultimate evolution of
human destiny and never be separated
from Americans the intensely practical
you know we are no longer a world power
not a superpower we and the Americans
share common ideals common heritage
common goals stick to them and he
believed that I found a letter which he
wrote in 1916 he's always a man of
foresight in which he said from now on
you noses after the United States had
come into World War one but have not yet
sent its troops over and he knew that
until the American troops came there
could be no victory over Germany on the
Western Front and he wrote nine sixteen
everything now the future of the world
depends on the United States the fact
that she's a democracy the fact that she
is you know basically a decent country
that she doesn't intend to
that is the way the world will go
forward in the 20th century and we must
make sure were associated with not only
so that we can right now be protected or
get rich but because this is the side
we're on he was Prime Minister how many
times and from what years he was Prime
Minister twice he was first of all Prime
Minister of 1948 1945 in 1940 that the
government had had basically tried to
pursue a war on a party basis a
Conservative Party which was in power
running the war and this was not
satisfactory to the British people and
it was not good for the conduct of the
war and there was a great demand from
the Labour Party that they should have a
place and generally from people of no
party that you know the war should be
seen to be a united effort at the top
because after all the workers were
having to work 24 hours a day shifts you
know multiple shift and so he became
prime minister of an all-party
government and that was his finest hour
really and one of the things I show in
the book was his enormous ability to
give each person hit the authority he
needed within his sphere of war
administration in other Anna's Bevin who
was a Labour man of distinction and he
was made Minister of Labour was given
somehow a free rein to organize the
labour as we call stretch was never an
anti-union man that was an interesting
aspect but still he brought in all
partisan he brought in professionals and
then in 1945 when the war was ending the
British public said let's go back to
party politics and to hell with the
Conservative Party who betrayed us
before the war and of course Churchill
had been one of those who had always
cried out the Conservatives are
betraying us before the war not standing
up to Hitler not rearming the nation not
getting on good terms of the United
States so he played his part in his own
defeat in 1945 because people gave a
thumbs down to the conservative but he
then became leader of the party or
leader of the Opposition and he rebuilt
the Conservative Party brought in young
men like Harold Macmillan who was later
Prime Minister and RA Butler was later
chance leaks checkup the head of the
Treasury and he gave them great
authorities for example he gave
Macmillan the brief of devising a
housing policy not unlike Jack Kemp
present housing policy you know you must
build houses
and on a scale which is commensurate
with the needs and so the the public
responded to this they saw that the old
Churchill that somehow created a new
party and they voted him back in and he
became prime minister of the second time
in 1951 and he remained Prime Minister
through his 80th birthday for another
four and a half years till 1955 and one
nice thing is that when he retired he
said I'm not going to interfere my
successors have had their training they
got their opportunity and although he's
always thought of a some sort of
interfering person he left them alone
and at the time of the serious crisis
when aunt Ann Eden his successor went to
war with Egypt and no the United States
opposed Britain's action Churchill had
certain views and he didn't want to make
them public he didn't want to embarrass
Eden so he set off from his motorcar
from his little country house about four
hours drive from where Eaton was at that
time and halfway he pulled into a lay-by
and dictated to a sector a little note
just a page drove onto Eden's residents
left it you know at the door and
returned back another four hours drive
is here a week doesn't go by in this
country were some politicians somebody
making a speech somewhere quotes Winston
Churchill as saying something to the
effect it was Winston Churchill that
said democracy is the worst form of
government except for every other form
something I mean people always doing
something with that what was the real
story that's what he said of course what
I I share Mario Cuomo's view that
everything has to be taken in context
I've been following this debate where
the Cuomo should declare himself or not
and one of the papers quoted him saying
exactly thirty days ago and I began my
trip tried to help my book on its way
and and and he said everything has to
put in its context has to be weighed and
studied in its context and I understood
exactly what he meant because what
Churchill was really saying was you are
flirting with fascism you are flirting
with communism another one is flirting
with some extreme right or extreme left
view but when all said and
democracy for all its faults is the only
way forward and he believed it you know
as I said you asked me earlier his life
was spent in Parliament and he was
always prepared to first about and
wishes upon and to argue his case very
carefully before Parliament and here he
one of the things that comes out in the
book is that he he he had enormous
numbers of enemies enormous setbacks
it's not a study in failure because I
don't believe church was a failure and
certain his ideas weren't failures but
it was a it's a study in setbacks and
blows I mean not only the physical blow
he was squashed flat on Fifth Avenue and
86th Street 931 I mean almost into a
pancake and nobody thought he would
survive but the blows of defeat the
blows of Parliament turning against him
the blows of the government refusing to
follow his lead and his incredible
resilience in bouncing back so I mean
it's one of the features of the book
that even as a school kid he was being
accused of things which he hadn't done
and was having to defend himself and
recently I I read in the paper that vice
president Quayle was being accused of
some involvement in drugs and drug
trafficking and I wanted to write him
and say look don't take it tragically
when Churchill was 20 and a young
soldier he was accused of buggery and
you know that's you know a terrible
accusation well he ended up Prime
Minister it just quite a long time where
was it accused of buggery and what is it
you don't know what buggery is we find
it oh dear sorry I thought the word with
the bugger is what used to be called uh
an unnatural act of the Oscar Wilde type
it's had was actually phrased in the
euphemism of the British papers it's you
don't know about this and when was he
and it's a very nasty thing which men
and do each other
he was accused by a fellow cadet at
Sandhurst who had a grievance against
Churchill Churchill was very successful
he was a successful mapmaker is a very
successful horse rider and somehow you
know this young man
he
understood that if you make an
accusation against Winston Churchill the
even the 20 year old energetic ambitious
appearing everywhere views on everything
a nasty accusation could stick enough
people would say hmm absol something to
it perhaps this man is a deviant
actually is a bugger and Churchill had
to bring a libel action which he won and
it was the first of I suppose 30 libel
actions in his career which he had to
bring against this sort of charge and he
once escaped from a prisoner of war camp
in South Africa as a young man got over
the wall and his political enemy said
our he didn't really escape he had given
his parole and he had promised you know
that he would behave and he was going to
be let out and then just as a show-off
knowing that he was going to be let out
he broke his parole and jumped over the
wall and and this was untrue and I went
to South Africa and I found the actual
prison authorities correspondence which
it's clear that they refused to give him
any special treatment that they said he
will be held here even more carefully
guarded than the other prisoners because
he's a troublemaker he'll he'll write
about the war and so on and he really
did have to jump over the wall and had a
very extraordinary series of very narrow
escapes with death before he got back to
England and of course as an escapee he
was a hero and that's what propelled him
into Parliament a young man who had
jumped over the wall
he told us when we started this that
this picture was new and that you found
it in Canada right anything else knew
about this in this volume stuff that you
didn't have in your other 8 do you know
there's probably something new on every
page it was my it was my ambition that
you would open the book anywhere and
read a page and say halfway down I never
knew that that is new and over all sorts
of things all sorts of I mean like the
letter which he wrote when he escaped
from the prisoner of war camp which he
left under his pillar and the grandson
of the Commandant the prison comment and
gave it to me in Pretoria came to see me
Pretoria by the way we have this left
and so it's full of lovely new things
full of little aspects of history which
perhaps have been neglected and
forgotten and also his humor and his his
all roundness you mentioned his painting
I mean he he he wasn't an obsessive man
about politics he was obsessive about
right and wrong but right and wrong in
the widest sense even fairness you know
in the family he made sure for example
that when he went abroad to his
conferences if one child went to one if
Randolph went to one then he'd asked his
daughter Sarah to another expensive fare
he he he hated anything which smacked of
unfairness of social unfairness
political unfairness and of course
international unfairness the evil of
totalitarianism that was his great enemy
and he never compromised with evil
though he understood that sometimes your
country could be so weak that there's
nothing you could do and you had to see
things which you believed in blotted out
that's what happened to calls of the
Yalta Conference where he fought so hard
and incidentally Roosevelt did not
betray the democracy some Americans have
been taught both in a way and their
staffs fought so hard for a democratic
Poland but the Red Army had already
occupied Poland and there was no way in
which they could make war on Stalin and
therefore you know the fait accompli was
there what I found and put in this book
was that Churchill wanted to hold the
older conference before the Red Army had
overrun Eastern Europe when you still
could have some sort of argument and
bargaining and of course you still had
your armies to direct in particular
directions and he proposed of course
Yalta was something came up later he
proposed Jerusalem as the site of the
conference why because Roosevelt who
could only travel by ship could go all
the way to Haifa port of the Quincy and
because Stalin who would only travel by
train could go from Moscow to Jerusalem
by train in those days and Churchill
even sent him the railway route and as
it were the the timetable and Churchill
who was older and sicker than both of
them in a curious way would fly but they
turned down the traditional conference
start and said he didn't want to leave
Russia and Reza
he couldn't need the United States
because because he had the elections
coming up October was very close to
November and it may be that the
Jerusalem conference would have done
what Yalta couldn't do but the ifs of
history are not for me therefore the
novelist who comes along afterwards
anything about him you didn't like well
you know I wasn't in the business of
liked and disliked sometimes I read
things of his which I felt oh dear you
know I wouldn't have said that or I
wouldn't have done that and sometimes I
read things I said goodness me how wise
how extraordin but I felt my job wasn't
to impose that judgment on the reader I
had to say to the reader to you this is
what he really stood for this what he
really did what he really said you may
like it or you may not like it I mean
one very clear example he believed that
Britain should relinquish Southern
Ireland Catholic Ireland and established
and he negotiated he established itself
the Irish Free State he brought in the
Irish free state bill an independent
Catholic government in Dublin which
exists to this day now many British
conservatives regarded that as the thin
end of the wait you know this was the
heartland of the bridge Empire you know
to give up Dublin you know what he give
up next Windsor Castle so you know if
you were a British conservative with
that perspective on Ireland you would
find that a very distressing chapter and
many people who for example he wanted
the Jews to have a national home in a
state and he believed that arrangements
should be made so that the Jews could
become a majority even if Arabs had to
become a minority for that reason
persuaded Roosevelt to exclude Palestine
from the terms of the Atlantic Charter
which would have given one man one vote
in 1945 and meant an Arab majority and
he said no I'm committed to a Jewish
majority investor now many people find
that offensive and even racist
I thought I even read one American blog
recording racist because of this sort of
attitude but that's for you to decide I
mean it'll depend on your perspective
and your your view of events was he an
interferer
I mean that's something which you know
people say well it's very distressing
how he interfered then I found an
example of his interference in 1921 he
said to the British government in Bagdad
we ought to establish an independent
homeland for the Kurds in northern Iraq
because one day a government in Iraq
might come to being which will persecute
the curb well his advisor said this is
interference you know this is what a
biographer will say you know look at
that bad news and they wrote him a
letter and they said we're not prepared
to do this because Britain will always
be able to exercise in restraining
influence in Baghdad well they were
wrong we now know they were wrong but if
you were reading it from the perspective
of a civil servant and administrator it
would be one more example of this
unpleasant feature of always interfering
always knowing better he live in 90 he
smokes cigars every day well he lit
cigars every day didn't always smell did
he drink a lot in moderation he drank a
lot he'd like nice wine good what I can
strongly recommend you some of the wines
he liked but if you were to drink his
whiskey and water you would say why
hasn't someone put some whiskey in this
world did he eat a lot of red meat
constantly loved red meat yes on one
occasion went when he was when he was
coming from Ottawa to to Washington he
was served an enormous American steak or
on the train he said I I I'm not a
cannibal he doesn't understand you it's
so much with me but he loved food he was
a great eater he could sometimes eat a
whole roast chicken for breakfast he had
an insatiable appetite he loved good
food
he loved what he called an important
pudding if he was given a dessert which
was nothing much to it he'd say this
pudding has no theme he liked it liked
it to be important he had a voracious
appetite and he you know he enjoyed
every aspect of life
to the fool he helped a lot yes he gave
us a good sleeper he retinol so now you
know he's almost the only person I've
come across I don't know what the
president United States does have
interesting to know but before he went
to bed he arranged for all the
newspapers which of course will publish
in our country at about midnight to be
to get all the newspapers and he read
all the newsmen didn't just read you
know the London Times he read the Times
and The Guardian News Chronicle and the
popular papers on the NASS circulation
paper and even the communist paper he
only cut out the communist paper when he
was so hard up that his wife said
darling we must cut down on the papers
we haven't got enough money and then he
reluctantly took out the Communist paper
and one or two others but he read all
the paper and he read them he absorbed
them and anything in them that he found
that smacked of that he didn't like or
all that caught some sparked his
imagination he would follow it up he
would call in a shorthand writer and
dictator and even ministers were often
surprised in the morning to get a minute
from him saying I see in the papers that
you know your department has done this
or that and please pray tell me why he
said pray tell me this Plato and they
were known as his prayers and God helped
the minister who didn't have an answer
or couldn't find somebody to give an
answer was he faithful to his wife he
was absolutely faithful to her he adored
his wife and he he was a very he was
faithful his the honest man he he had
very high moral standards and people
understood that and I found and I told
the story once or twice in the book but
when other ministers even of the
opposition part were in some trouble of
the sort nowadays of course would make
the headlines sex or financial they
would go to him they knew that he would
somehow give them good and disinterested
advice and would be totally discreet and
never tell anybody about now that's an
extraordinary thing no you know I I've
always thought that tells you something
of his qualities because it's not you
know Winston Churchill the war leader
and the monolith and
and the man with the frown it's a man to
whom people who are even his opponents
went for advice and guidance he was a
very good guide and he he had a various
sort of you know little stand to think
if someone came to know I don't know
well to do this or not I mean this
example that's what should not mention
in the Cuomo context but he used to say
when you're in doubt as to whether to
lay an egg or not don't in other words
you know if something is really bugging
you you're not sure whether you should
do it or not don't do it and he he had
these various sort of little rules of
thumb and last question what is Martin
Gilbert going to do for the rest of his
life well Martin Gilbert I know him
quite well he's got a few ideas he's got
to finish Churchill's wartime documents
which will be a five volume set and then
he's embarking upon a three-volume
history of the 20th century and he hopes
that we'll see him out to the end of the
century this is what the book looks like
it's called Churchill a life by his
official biographer Martin Gilbert thank
you very much for joining thank you